shawn o'shea joins us live now from
ottawa with the latest good afternoon
sean
well candace it is absolutely chaotic
here we're at colonel by near rito you
can see the crowds right here these are
mostly protesters some journalists but
beyond these crowds are just an enormous
number of police officers tactical
officers regular officers we have police
on horseback
toronto police mounted unit is here
people carrying flags now the protesters
are face to face with the police so
they're just we're just going to work
walking up in
closer here
we've been told anybody in the area
where we are right now is subject to
arrest
the police started moving in about an
hour ago and here we have public order
unit to police officers face to face
with protesters
who said and have said that they will
not leave
we saw the tactical units roll in here
it's just an enormous number of people
that they wanted to keep people away as
much as possible which is why they
sealed off downtown ottawa virtually as
much as possible only people who live
here or work here were supposed to be
allowed downtown here today so some of
these people are part of the protest
directly uh some of the people have come
in from elsewhere uh many of the most of
the journalists here have security
because the the threats and the concerns
are are significant here but as you can
see people are
eyeball to eyeball we have toronto
police on the front line right here
these are all toronto police on this
particular cordon we saw london police
york regional police tactical units from
various police departments including
york and the point here is that they're
you know they're trying to get closer
and closer to the
protest trucks which needs to come okay
on the other side
thank you very much sir that's the
people kind of got a sense of things but
they keep saying a peaceful protest all
the lies
this is
pretty much what we've been hearing for
the last couple of weeks anyway this is
the protest these are the police this is
the action and we're going to send it
back to you candace
okay thank you that's sean o'shea live
in ottawa